Herkese merhaba zaten kahvaltı Nuray
O çok az stres olurum hayatta gerçekten
hep oynamayı Alışığım sayısı karşısında
mı Bir oturup konuşmak gerçekten çok güç
çok da Tercih ettiğim birşey değil ama
sizlerin karşısında olmaktan gerçekten
çok mutluyum konuşmayı biraz kendi
hayatımdan anlatmak istedim bunu tercih
ettim çünkü konuda çok bağlantılı
olduğunu düşünüyorum
o o
bu protr vardı mı kullanmayacağım
abone ol
bu konuşma eski bir efsane ile başlamak
istiyorum mitolojiden Farsça simurq
olarak bilinen günümüzde anka kuşu
olarak hepimizin bildiği efsane bu kuş
dünyanın yıkılışına üç kez tanıklık
etmiş aynı zamanda Efsaneye göre yeniden
küllerinden doğduğuna inanılan efsanem
bu efsane çocukken çok küçükken
duymuştum ve çok etkilenmiştim
var Yani bu beni gerçekten çok etkileyen
olaylardan biri oldun şunun ne zaman
öyle ya da böyle kendimi içinde dolandım
labirentin sonuna geldiğini hissetsem ve
yolun sonunda peynir olmadığını fark
etsem Ben her zaman derim ki hadi sarkan
Aramaya devam et abi o peynir mutlaka
bulacaksın
o zaman zaman içinde kaybolduğunda
olduğu yolun sonuna geldiğimde Buldun mu
derseniz
bu çocuk ya bana soruyorlardı büyüyünce
ne olacaksın diye bu vampir derdim Şimdi
Derin Bir Sessizlik olurdu Annem
bayılırdı ama bankir olamadım penüs
vampirlikten sonra ikili seçtiği meslek
oyunculuk oldu Oldu çocuk yaşlarda
seslendirme yapmaya başladım bugün
mikrofona yetişmez di bütün Gençliğim
Çocukluğum hayatımın en güzel zamanları
oyuncuların arasında geçti ve Tabi ki bu
mesleği seçmem şans eseri değil diye
düşünüyorum ve yine Ankaralı olarak
Ankara'da bu sokaklarda böyle kulağımda
bokmen ve bir aşağı bir yukarı yürüyerek
buradaki sinemalarda günde bazen İki
defa üç defa sinemaya gidip film
izleyerek ki
ve bu şehri soluyarak ve bugünlerin
hayalini kurarak geçirdim
bu ikililerinden doğuşum Bilkent
Üniversitesi tiyatro bölümünü tam bursu
kazanarak ve aynı zamanda Hacettepe
Üniversitesi Ankara Devlet
konservatuarı'nda kazanarak Çok havalı
bir girişli oldu ya müthiş bir
öğrencilik geçirdim 3. sınıfta iken de
culverts kulda 4aylık biraz programına
kabul edildim ki çok önemli bir program
the xx yaşındaydım en iyi oradaydım daha
sonra döndüm o sene okuldan mezun oldum
diplomamı bile almadan aynı hafta New
York'a gittim Master yapmak ve o dışında
hazırlanmak için o bir buçuk ilk Bir
buçuk sene Bir dilimi daha iyi hale
getirmek için okula giderek ve aynı
zamanda bir ayakkabıcıda satış elemanı
olarak çalışarak geçtim Babam da aynı
Bana Herkes bu okulu kazanamazsın o
dilime giremezsin orada zaman
kaybediyorsun buraya gel Ne yapıyorsun
orada falan derken ben kulağımı takayım
hiç kimseyi dinlemeden yoluna devam
ediyordum
11 buçuk sene
bu üç kişilik koltukta uyuyarak Haftada
altı gün dokuz saat ayakta durarak ve
hiç oturmayacak çalışarak ve kazandığım
parayı da oyunculuk derslerine
harcayarak geçiriyordum ilk Selam viltis
kolaydı o kadar stresli idim ki
heyecandan ilk dakika İngilizce unuttum
öyle durdum sonra hatırladım ama iş
işten geçmişti dünyanın en kötü dışında
vererek mükemmel bir başlangıç yaptım
arkasından yıl Üniversitesi'ne girdim en
büyük hayalim okula girmekte cebimde 35
dolarla New York'tan konektikıt trenle
gidip ilk kol bekle başarı sağladım
ikinci kolback bir hafta sonu 3. kolda 4
5 6 7 son kol ve kaldı iki kişi kaldık
ve eğlendim
Ne sınavı kilisede yapılıyordu kilisenin
bahçesine çıktım Şu mo gün hayatımda en
büyük hayal kırıklığıdır o banka oturdum
ve yaklaşık üç üç buçuk saat durmadan
ağladım
Az önce Daha sonra bir daha olmayacak
herhalde Başaramayacağım diye düşünürken
depola sınavı vardı bu yapamayacağım
diye düşünüp sınava girdim ve kazandım
başardım yani Ama hesaplamadan başka bir
şey vardı 11eylül o uşaklar sadece ikiz
kulelere çarpan da aynı zamanda bana da
çarptı o sene burs alamadım ve kaydıma
bir yıldan duracaklarını söylediler Berk
kalktı mı İstanbula geldiğim için teklif
almıştım Bir yılda kaç para kazanırım
diye düşündüm bir yılına Geldim 20
senedir İstanbul'dayım 20 yıl boyunca
kaç kere küllerimden doğdum sayısını
İnanın ben de hatırlamıyorum ama hayat
bana derslerini sadece kurduğum
hayalleri üzerinden vermiyordu 2006
yılında bir anda babamın kanser olduğunu
ve 8 ay ömrü kaldığını öğrendik
Ama bu benim için çok büyük bir kötü
sürpriz dedim şimdi bunu öğrendikten
3'er sonra ilk baş rol aldığı dizide
sette kaza ile kurusıkı tabancaya kendi
kafamdan vurdum
İyi tamam bu olay bu sefer şimdiye kadar
düşündüğüm yani hesaplama dım
düşünmediğim bir kolaylık gerçekten
karşı karşıya kalmıştım asıl küllerinden
doğma gereken bu zamanmış ama benim
haberim yokmuş beyin kanaması çorabın
bile giyemeyecek durumdayken dört gün
yoğun bakım on gün hastane bu kafam
saklı eve döndüm bu evden çıkarken
bambaşka bir Saklandım Kapıyı açıp içeri
girdiğinde bambaşka birim unutmayın
Ama bu ayın sonunda çok fazla öğretiye
katıldım hiç konuşmadım Kimseye
anlatmadım anlatmayı tercih ettim kendi
içimde yaşadım Çok sevdiğim de fikrine
güvendiğim biri bana dedi ki bu olayı bu
yaşadıklarını anlatmak istediğin zaman
doğru zamandır Ve bunu duyması gereken
insanlara gerçekten ihtiyacı olan
insanları anlatacaksın dır lütfen
anlatmaktan çekinmem ve bunu ilk defa
bir kalabalığın karşısında anlatıyorum
Bundan daha doğru bir zaman olamaz diye
düşünüyorum
o o
Bu olaydan
15 ay sonra babamı kaybettim
ben Ankara'daydım birinci haftasıydı
m'dir arkadaşım aradı Kürklü Merkür diye
bir oyun var ve o da için açıyorlar
girmek ister misin dedim o an
hatırladığım tek şey Biz okunuşunu
öğretirler baban o sebeple saniye
çıkacaksın bu ki gerçekten katılmıyorum
zorunlu olmadıkça da ama nedense bunu
hatırladım dedim ki bunu test etmekten
daha iyi bir zaman olamaz aynı gün
arabayla İstanbul'a döndü mod içindeki
gün vardı Çok iyi ezber yaparım
Sen hiçbir şey yapma tutamıyorum zar zor
ezberledim bu içine girdim ve kazandım o
oyun kaderimin başlangıcıdır
bu oyunla beraber gerçekten küllerimden
doğdum ilk andı bu sefer kanatlarımı
takmış uçuyordum yani oyunları sinema
filmleri diziler vesaire arka arkaya hiç
durmadan yıllarca durmadan günde belki
3-4 saat uyuyarak bir asker gibi yaşadım
çalışmaya devam ettim hiç yılmadım hiç
hiç şikayet etmedim hala de etmiyorum
bu Aman ben şunu hatırladım kim
Bu hayat bana sadece şunu hatırlatmıyor
Muş yani şu andan itibaren şu andan
itibaren Şu hayatın Şu andan ibaret
olmadığını Gerçekten ne istersek
başarabileceğimi gerçekten olan
biliyordum ve Neyse daha fazla
uzatmayayım arada daha ne hikayeler ve
olaylar ne Anılar var bu Seçtiklerim o
anlatım kısaca kendi hayat hikayem
Sizler C gerçekten paylaşmak istediğim
Hayaller umutlar Hayal kırıklıkları
inişler çıkışlar Düşler kalkışta üzerine
kısa bir kesit tirbi
abone ol
bu hayatta gerçekten Her şey ikimiz için
sen buna inandın kim olursanız oğlum
isterseniz Doktor isterseniz Profesör
isterseniz sanatçı isterseniz güvenlik
görevlisi kim olursanız olun Hayat
hepimize eşit uzaklıkta Hayat içinizdeki
dengeyi bulmak Her ne olursa olsun kim
ne derse desin kendi bildiğiniz
doğrulardan şaşmadan yola devam etmeye
çalışmak sonunda kendi ettiğiniz
başarılardan da başarısızlıklardan da en
azından ben dedim Ben elimden geleni
yaptım demek kadar insanı büyüten bir
şey olmayacağını düşünüyorum hepimiz çok
zordu kuşağın insanlarıyız
bu şartların ve dünyanın hepimiz için
giderek daha da zorlaştığını ve daha da
kötüye gideceğini Biliyorum bu küs
sağlığımız 5 varlığımız devam ettiği
sürece bi ama çağrıya gerçekten
uzaklardan aramak gerektiğini
düşünüyorum
ya o yüzden bencillikten uzak daha çok
paylaşarak anlayarak anlatarak dürüstçe
konuşarak koruyarak ve en önemlisi
sevdiklerimize ve ailemize daha çok
sarılarak birbirimizi sevip değer
vererek ilerlersek başarının ve
mutluluğun kaçınılmaz bir şey olduğunu
artık biliyorum
ya o yüzden Sizden ricam hepinizden
Lütfen daha çok müzik dinleyin daha çok
tiyatro oyununa gidin daha çok operaya
gidin daha çok dans izleyin İnan her
şeyin değiştiğini göreceksiniz
Ya ben son olarak sizden bir ricam var
bu
Ben bu hayatta size sunulan şeylerle
getirmeyin
2000'li fen reddettim
Sen kabul etme yine önemlisin bir
yeniden doğmaktan korkmayın düşün kalkın
ama bildiğiniz yolda devam edin Son
olarak şunu unutmayın anka kuşu Efsaneye
göre hala Bilgi ağacının tepesinde
dallarında yuvasında bizi izliyor ve
Bence hepimizi görüyor beğendiğiniz için
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]